yo it's Marlon craft you catch me live
on the bootleg Kev podcast
we got a special guest
Marlin craft my man welcome sir thank
you for having me man yes you and I have
been talking and pandemic happen and
I was like when are you coming to L.A
and you're finally here I'm finally here
it was like I took like a two or three
year break from coming out here I was
just like it's good to be back I love it
man yeah I mean obviously uh yeah I mean
you had a great pandemic though thank
you I mean obviously not I'm talking
about career yeah it sucked like but no
but I feel like you like leveled up
crazy during like that time period if
you will not to sound insensitive you
know but like yeah yeah I mean the
pandemic wasn't bad for you yeah yeah
yeah no I was like I was able to find a
lot of I went back independent and I was
able to kind of really find hone in on
my strategy and kind of figure out who I
want to be and just kind of set up like
a three-year type of plan that I'm kind
of in like year three of yeah explain
that though because like uh before you
were you not independent at a certain
point in time or did what was what was
your prior situation I was at a thing
called sane play it was like a JV uh at
Sony okay for that funhouse mirror album
yep yep okay so you get out of that deal
and then what walk me through your three
year plan and uh obviously it's been
it's worked so we should yeah what was
the plan yeah I mean I just realized I
learned a lot from being in that
situation and I realized what I had to
do and
um I was just like you know I need to
move at a pace where I could be
consistent and especially in the
pandemic when we're stuck at home like
all I could do was make music so I just
had this stock pile of music and all
these different projects going and I was
like I'm gonna figure out how to just be
really kind of relentlessly consistent
but combine that with keeping everything
quality and keeping it conceptual and
right keeping it me and um and I'm just
gonna build it and have faith in
you know doing it like that and that's
what I've kind of been doing yeah so for
you it was like because a lot of artists
uh there's something uh kind of just
went viral semi-viral recently I don't
know if you saw like Russ was telling
everybody
if you're on a come up in music drop
consistently don't sit on our music
right somebody had like made a response
and pretty much said it's terrible
advice and so for you it was like yo why
am I sitting on all this music I you
obviously you're recording at home at
the time yeah yeah recording yourself
yeah so it's like
what like a lot of people they do sit on
their music or they overthink releasing
their music or they I think everybody is
like very not everybody but a lot of
artists get wrapped up in like
Perfection and like a lot of things
having to be checked off yeah before
they think they can release something
yeah that's not always the case yeah I
mean so there's a couple things with
that like and your quality is high it's
not like you're doing like quantity over
quality you're doing both which is hard
to do yeah that I think is the key and I
appreciate that I think like I grew up
admiring like the Kohl's and the
Kendricks and these different people
that have kind of this Pantheon of their
catalog right where you could look at
like these four albums that are like
incredible right and so I think a lot of
us grow up wanting to be like that but
then when you really get back into the
industry I think that you realize that
it's not that these artists didn't want
to release more music and in the mixtape
era it's not even like they weren't they
were they were free zip files yeah it's
a warm up and all all that exactly and I
think it's just that like once you get
into a system in a situation like those
buildings move so slow a lot of times
it's not even their choice of how little
music they're releasing because they're
it's on a cycle so I had to get myself
out of that mindset and realize I
remember like watching something where
they were talking about how like the
week after Get Rich or Die try and drop
50 Cent drop the mixtape in the streets
yep and we don't remember necessarily
that mixtape in the streets but it
didn't dilute get rich or die trying you
know I mean so I was like okay first of
all people have always done this like
people have always had this kind of
abundance but then second of all like
you know I just realized that I had a
lot to say and I had a lot of material
and I felt like I could do it all
without compromising the quality yeah
and so that was kind of you know my mood
in terms of like the rusting and I saw
that dialogue going on yeah I think
everybody's different and you know you
know there's certain projects that you
want to take more time with and that's
why for me like the language of album
like I've only dropped you know three
albums right like that I consider albums
so as an artist like I kind of decipher
the things that I really spend years and
years working on whatever so the fans
know what's what I think that's
important but everything I think I think
it gets confused because now instead of
it being like a mixtape you buy from the
corner store or something on that piff
everything's on dsps as it should be I
feel like you're crazy like I just
somebody recently put something out and
it was like only on Soundcloud and like
DatPiff and I was just
I mean shout out to that you know but
like it just didn't make sense it's like
why wouldn't you anyway but yeah I just
think like you said it's important like
communicating the language of like what
this is to your fans like yo this is a
mixtape or this is just some
collection of Records or any P or
whatever
so for you
how do you kind of differentiate because
you say you're working on your big album
how do you differentiate between like
what makes the album is it because the
album has a certain concept or there's a
certain feel or quality to it like how
do you know if that's high oh this is an
album song yeah we just can't throw this
out there yeah when it feels like that
when it feels like man this is something
that I have to cultivate this feels like
the expression of my sound that combines
a lot of my different influences but
that like this is where I'm at musically
at this point in time and creatively and
this is what I want to say and you know
when it fits into The Narrative of the
big album that I'm working on at the
time you know the other joints like the
obviously the space two which is you
know February 10th and then like the
home court projects that have kind of
like become these little serialized
things they just happened organically
creatively I was making really emotional
joints about this period of my life with
the space stuff that I was making like
this mixtape feeling like barred out
stuff for the home course stuff and I
was just like you people always feel
this pressure on albums when you don't
drop a lot of stuff just show them
everything I got in one go and it
sometimes makes for projects that aren't
cohesive a hundred percent so always
that pressure you know what I mean by
giving them the other stuff in a
cohesive form that's kind of the mo you
know I mean for you um
I feel like a lot of people who come
from New York
um like I mean if we think of New York
like nationally at the moment obviously
there's like the big the Great Stuff the
cardi B's and the uh I mean [__] the
Joey badasses and these guys who are
like well established but it feels like
right now in New York everyone is very
much um
not everybody but nationally a lot of
people are checking for the drill scene
you kind of coming out of the city doing
something way different do you feel like
it's like an advantage for you because
you kind of because it's a lot of drill
[__] coming out of New York and I feel
like for you it's kind of probably a
good thing that you're bringing a
different you know piece of music or
style to the landscape of New York hip
hop how do you feel
um yeah I think so to be totally honest
with you you know like
I just I am New York because of New York
raised me like for real for real and at
this point like I don't really think too
directly about
how it all relates to New York I've been
like doing a lot of just finding myself
and who I am and what like Marlon craft
represents and that's always going to be
inherently New York but I don't even
think about like
where does this fit into the landscape
and I've just been watching it kind of
grow and observing which places support
what I'm doing more and you know New
York's always home-based and is
everything to me but I don't even really
like consider it though could you ever
leave New York
I'm it's real sunny out here bro I'm
gonna tell you something man I go to New
York and I love it but I'm just like God
bless y'all man because y'all really
lived there I couldn't do it I I
understand though like there's one thing
like like to me like if you like when
they say you if you could survive in New
York you could survive anywhere it's
[__] a fact yeah because just like
going to the store or going to work just
there's so many variables every day that
you have to deal with you wouldn't deal
with anywhere else that it's it's almost
like you're numb to the stress that
those variables create yeah it's kind of
wild yeah yeah it's like I saw a video
of a guy sleeping on the subway and just
a rat was like running on him and [__]
he just like flicked it off like it was
just like I saw that that was wild bro
if there was a rat on me bro going on
but like we don't see Rats on the west
coast like that but in New York if like
you're eating pizza on the corner with
your boys after the club there's like
rats running around and she's like yeah
just [__] yeah it's just you guys
deal with a lot dude a lot of stress
yeah a lot of [__] people a lot of
rubbing shoulders yeah the pandemic had
to be extra stressful that was really
hard because there's so little space and
so everybody's on top of each other bro
like I mean I say this the older I get
and the more in tune I get with like
what's really important to me and what's
better for my mental health the more I'm
like wow this is not that conducive to
that you know like when I come to place
even out here for to take breaks you
know it's like the weather's warm the
sunshine and there's more space it's
calmer like some of these things whereas
when I was younger I would have been
like man this [__] boring like I got
fomo I gotta get back home now I'm like
really embracing those things a lot more
but it's hard for me to Envision leaving
New York for like year round because
it's just no matter there's nothing like
going when you're from New York there's
nothing like going back to New York you
know what I mean no it's one of one
place yeah it's it's a great place man
what is your favorite like okay you're
for Mel's Kitchen which is a huge uh
food area yeah what's like your top
three restaurants in Hell's Kitchen
oh [__] Yelp man you know what's crazy
this [__] is so different now the whole
Manhattan is cooked like like
gentrified's not even the word like it's
just like Beyond oh I go on Zillow once
a month just for shits and giggles to
just scare myself from ever taking a job
in New York yeah bro it's bro it's so
expensive yo it's cooked so it like I to
tell you the truth like every time I'm
in a house kit it's like new stores new
restaurants everything popping up like
every other day
um I don't even know what do we like
Claudio shout out to claudios claudios
is the only like real house kitchen spot
that's still there Pizzeria that's the
pizzeria yeah Claudio's I shot a video
in there back in the day that's like you
know that's that's like the spot and
it's still there it's like he renovated
it and whatever but it's still like
that's the spot yeah how we feeling
about Jalen Brunson Julius Randle and
these Knicks that are actually you know
playing like
playing for the hardest [__] coach to
play for in the whole league oh man it's
a [__] [__] how much time do
we have man well how do you feel you
know well you know I feel good it's nice
that we're that we're more competitive
Brunson I think was the best off-season
signing for sure and I love his game and
he's not that expensive yo compared to
like other players who are doing what
he's doing yeah he's a beast I'm really
happy about that what I will say is if
you really watch the games it's brutal
man it's still brutal because even when
we win
we [__] like find a way to blow it at
the end and make it like like a shitty
win where like it was like we were up by
10 the whole game and then we collapsed
because everyone's tired and Tom
Thibodeau plays him [__] yeah and
then and it's very weird bro like we
have a winning record but we have a
losing home record we're like one of the
only teams in the league and I don't
know if it's because New York's popping
and so the road is like we just we just
chill and don't go out and they go out
we go out in New York I don't know but
it's very it's very uh it's still been
like a frustrating up and down year but
I'm in it forever man with these Knicks
would you train RJ Barrett
oh man
I never know how honest to be with this
[__] because you know I'd like to uh to
do things with the Knicks and you know I
do things with the sun yeah yeah and I I
will be my Twitter if if if the sun's
ever checked my Twitter feed yeah I
probably wouldn't do stuff with the sun
all right I'll keep it a buck with you
the thing with RJ is
dudes told him he was a star then gave
him the bag that he was a star but he's
not a star because he's the third best
player on our team and we're not even
good and he can't and and he stopped
playing defense he used to play D well
but he got so into what's going on with
him and his scoring then now he stops
playing defense but he shoots low
percentage from the field so to be
honest like what are we really talking
about as the ceiling and I like the
things he does and I think he's a young
good player but is he gonna accept
what his role might have to be to be
part of a contender because
how much more evidence do we need to
know if he's going to be a star player
on a winning team what is it like here
three or four I think it's four or five
I think it's four I think it's four yeah
because him and Zion came in the same
year yeah yeah and Zion's obviously a
star who just gets injured a lot cam
reddish is the cam reddish on the Knicks
he is he's been relegated to the bench
wow it's like Duke some people are real
some people are real tight about that
that cam reddish is on the bench oh yeah
I don't know I have league pass but I
don't watch enough when the Knicks are
on I'm not running to the game yeah I
feel you there's some teams that I don't
give a [__] about but if they're playing
I'm like oh let me see what the kings
are doing yeah if the Warriors playing
I'm watching yeah if it's you yeah yeah
sorry that's that's a sore spot I mean
not so much the
sun's yeah
yeah you guys are having I have I have
no sympathy because I've been Nick's
family all up but but you're having a
you at least got championships not when
you were alive yeah but at least my dad
out of my dad's youth yeah we don't got
that [__] yeah I mean you yeah
you guys got at least the cultural
importance the sons don't gives a [__]
about the Suns yeah everyone hates us
though but it's kind of it's kind of fun
I'm loving watching the Nets Crash and
Burn that's mine it is actually pretty
dope because they really thought that
like they were gonna go yeah like when
heart like like y'all really had
hardened Kyrie and Katie and it just
didn't matter and all five of their fans
talk so much [__] five of them yeah no
one's come on I've noticed some people
from New York switching sides or double
dipping like our guy Rob Markman is one
of one of those guys the hardcore Knicks
guy hardcore but you know what he's not
so hardcore when he did it I I couldn't
even be mad at him it's like when
porzingis left it was the same thing it
was like yo you gotta understand this is
an abusive household yeah people want to
get out right you can't hold them back
and I don't think Dolan will sell until
he dies no and he'll probably pass it on
to some other jerk off yeah you said I
said it not you exactly
um so for you man uh I think that
you got three million monthly listeners
on Spotify
that's a serious accomplishment thank
you outside of dropping music at a high
quantity at a high level
what would you say would be the key to
you connecting with people connecting
with the fans uh what what because
you've conceptually you've put out some
of the Doper videos in recent memory
thank you
um but like for you that's a that's
crazy especially because there's guys
that have quote unquote bigger buzzes
than you or you know are perceived to be
bigger artists than you that aren't even
sniffing that so for you what has been
the
one key or a couple keys that have has
worked for you
to connect on that level man so you know
I think just staying true like obviously
there's tactical things like on a
strategic breakdown or whatever but I
think like really honing in on
what is resonating with people like not
I'll give you an example like my biggest
song on Spotify is a song called
something's wrong in heaven and I made
that song in 2019 when I was still in
that in that deal right and when I made
it I was in a little bit in the world I
was like in the industry thing and I was
still staying true but I was doing this
thing that an artist do where it's like
man if something is not like something
new for me it feels like oh it's not
enough like it was like this is just a
dope beat it's a crazy loop sample
profound words yeah but everyone knows I
can do that I I don't I don't know this
new [__] yeah hop on a different video
yeah and so but even when people around
me like this song is really special
whatever so I put that song out three
years later and it's now my biggest song
and I got out of that headspace and into
the headspace of just what is it that I
do for people what is it that people
resonate with in my music and allowing
the fans to decide which songs are their
favorites and not trying to police
what people resonate with about me but
rather just learn from it and just keep
hammering down on what that is and then
being consistent and um and just knowing
who I am and trying to trying to be
honest and be forthright you know
hey we got to stop the interview to tell
you about our folks at my bookie that's
right baby Super Bowl is coming well you
know in a month or so we got the
playoffs right now you could get those
future bets in on who you think out of
this uh barrage of teams that made it to
the playoffs is going to win the Super
Bowl you could bet player props we can
go NBA action on them so much ways to
make money with all the sports going on
and you could do it all at my bookie
right now if you go to my bookie and you
sign up for a new account use the promo
code bootleg and they will match your
first deposit up to a thousand dollars
you know what's dope about my bookie not
only can you bet on your favorite sports
but you could also get a little
Blackjack going little slot machines in
that thing yummy a little loud little
roulette yeah me so much ways to get
paid on my bookie the most important
thing is though if you sign up
and you use the promo code bootleg at my
bookie go to my bookie my bookie my
bookie my bookie use the promo code
bootleg and they're gonna match your
first deposit up to one thousand dollars
right [__] now
listen I'm a degenerate but I'm pretty
good at this
I've been using my bookie for like 10
years all right very trusted they're the
best trust me they are the [__] best
wherever you're at if you're watching
this you can sign up for my bookie
account one more time that's my book you
use the promo code bootleg and they will
double your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars free [__] money
let's get to it all right boys back to
the interview
hey what UPS bootleg cab here to uh stop
the interview and tell you about
Bluetooth yes do you have a dick does
your husband have a dick
maybe does your boyfriend got a dick
does your wife have a dick who knows
um it could be harder I'll tell you that
yeah blue chill get your dick real hard
to kick off that new year you know what
I'm saying if you want your dick harder
than
Advanced trigonometry senior year high
school then go to bluetooth.com right
now use the promo code bootleg and get
one month supply for free that's right
free all you got to do is pay five
dollars in shipping
they're going to deliver the blue shoe
right to your [__] door and discreet
packaging all right same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable form
very discreet packaging mailed to your
house you don't have to go to a doctor's
appointment in person with anybody you
don't have to worry about embarrassing
conversations with strangers about your
[__] dick bro nobody wants to talk
about their dick with a stranger I take
that back I take that back
lots of people like to talk about their
dicks with strangers
if you're not that kind of guy or girl
or them all you gotta do is go to
Bluetooth right now and use the promo
code
bootleg and you're gonna get it sent
straight to your door that's right they
also got the new mint chewable that's
the same active ingredients as Levitra
so there's a lot of options to get your
dick right in the New Year it's 2023.
yeah your dick shouldn't be flaccid
after a like nice long stressful night
no your dick should be ready you don't
want to be a you know a victim of too
much stress too much anxiety and then
you look down and you can't stay hard
you imagine how [__] embarrassing
that is you get yourself a nice lovely
[__] young lady you bring her to the
place you're nervous she's a little
maybe she's a little out of your [__]
league and you start thinking too much
and that dick's not gonna perform it's
not it's not going to perform how you'd
like it to but you know how it will
perform if you're on that [__]
Bluetooth
you're gonna put in a [__] Luka
donkic 61 Point [__] performance on
that [__] all right so go to
bluetooth.com right now use that promo
code bootleg let's get back to the
interview you're a hip-hop head who's
been the biggest what the [__] fan of
marlin craft where you found out they
[__] with you and you were just like
what like this is crazy like this person
knows who I am this person listens to my
music if I had a few of those
I'm trying to think man uh
there's people for sure
um
but none really come to mind
yeah Jaden Smith hit me one time on
Instagram and just sent me like a thumbs
up emoji that's pretty sick that was it
it was so Random I was like and I was
like yo where and that was it I never
heard anything it was just so that was a
weird one you know these hip-hop people
obviously but I mean like for me you
know I look like getting the respect
when I walk into a party and like you
know
Primo's there and like you know or I met
just blaze when he and I was like yo
you're my favorite producer ever hey
he's my favorite producer ever too yeah
and he's like yo I'm a fan he's my
favorite yeah like that those that's how
those type of things are crazy to me
like that was a crazy moment I met him
he's like yeah I'm a fan like that was
that was crazy I've had certain people
like reach out and send DMS but
um I mean just blazing Primo is pretty
[__] crazy but Jaden Smith's random
and awesome too it's like
that was just a random one I can't think
I couldn't think of it but it was so
weird I was just like okay that's that's
dope
what's your favorite just blaze beat
probably either public service
announcement or you don't know I love
breathe
oh that breathe beat is so hard
yeah oh that [__] is so cold to me he's
the illest man I mean I would love to to
do something you haven't worked with him
yet no no I you know I I don't wanna I
think when the time is right hopefully
it doesn't seem like he's like like I
feel like just is not as active as he
like not as I wouldn't say should be but
like as you would think like I don't
feel like I see just blaze beats often
and when I do I get super excited but I
feel like like he just doesn't work with
anybody yeah you know you know who's
probably the answer to that question the
original question is doing the song with
Havoc like doing the Hans Zimmer song
with Havoc like that was crazy to me
like the fact that he showed me love
because what they meant to me growing up
in New York and then how I popped up on
the scene like going viral on the
survival of the fittest beats like in my
childhood bedroom and [__] to then
having my own song that he produced and
he's not sat here popping up either like
you don't see him on upcoming artist
[__] like so that was real special to me
like that was like wow was that like a
song that
did you know he was like it was his beat
did you know he was getting on the
record
nah he wasn't on it he wasn't on it he
just did the beat yeah he just did the
beat but what's crazy is that like
that song too I made in 2020 and dropped
in 2022 I had it for that long
that's so crazy but that's dope because
like
like back like let that be a lesson the
artists who like they get demoitis yeah
where they have a song for so long and
they're like man that's just whack or it
just gets played out to you but like the
people haven't heard it it's like bro
yeah like don't overthink this [__] like
yeah here's here's here's the key thing
to our conversation even before with
like the consistency
like the
implication of people that are
critiquing it is you think I'm Russian
you're wrong because I'm dropping songs
that are two three years old I'm just
really two years ahead of myself like I
came into you I told you today like yo I
gotta Play This Album [__] I'm working
on bro for like 24. you know what I mean
these are songs some of these songs that
are on that they're gonna be on that
album I made in 2020. yeah no that's
right you're you got you got the next
couple things already planned out you
gotta work that way if you want to be
like strategic and not lose quantity
because I agree if you if you rush
things out for the sake of rushing them
out then it's gonna lose quality uh are
now that gambling is legal in New York
and you being the sports fan that you
are you dabbling in any uh in any sports
gambling I haven't dabbled yet and I'm
afraid to because I'm very like be very
afraid yeah I'm very compulsive with
certain things I'm like man I'm not plus
yo it's like I mean I think it's it's
fine but it's it's just wild how like
every commercial now is fanduel's and
it's everybody shamelessly and there's
like real people real ruin their lives
with this [__] it's mad addictive and
people get destroyed it was like a
commercial generator like yo like you
got Charles Barkley up there like all
right at halftime like all right we're
gonna pick who's gonna score the next
bucket it's almost like they're like all
right like we're gonna try out who got
the best crack like you know what it's
like I go kind of a wild concept it is
pretty crazy you know handling is very
addictive yeah especially if you're like
a hardcore sports fan because then like
you makes you just care so much about
every game yeah like you'll be betting
on like a [__]
a goddamn like Portland Trailblazers
versus Orlando Magic game and you'll
just be like locked in nobody else in
the country gives a [__]
yeah I'm kind of like that because I
play Fantasy so that does that you can
see basketball yeah yeah it like gives
me investment in games I don't give a
[__] fantasy basketball is great yeah
it's fun do you do it where you set your
lineup every day or set it once a week
every day yeah yeah but I just do it at
the beginning of the week I just it's
not like you don't have to think about
it you just whoever's playing do you do
football nah not a big football guy nah
man because I was I'm Jets fan and like
I can only tolerate so much like
dysfunction and disappointment with the
Knicks you and garyvee huh Jets guys oh
yeah I don't even know that poor Zach
Wilson he's done bro I'm out the loop
bro I got enough trauma and stress I'm I
okay yeah the Knicks the Knicks is all I
could take yeah yeah the next thing is
rough it's tough man it is tough um okay
so is there anything first of all mom's
whiskey the idea of you actually putting
out whiskey with your mom yeah his
[__] genius I appreciate it how is
the Whiskey Business and was that like a
super limited thing or is this something
that's like you're trying to scale like
and like really like get down on in the
alcohol industry it's super limited it's
been super limited so far we've just
done batches of like very limited
releases but I would love to scale it
it's a it's a it's a tricky thing
um the out because there's so many laws
that go back to like prohibition and
[__] yeah it's like also like a very
tricky industry it's like a lot of like
it's it's like any industry but it's got
you know
you got to kind of have somebody in that
industry to help guide you yeah I think
I think if like when I'm more pop and we
could probably like scale it but I think
like it's been really cool so far and we
just reached out to this Distillery and
they were down you know and that song
was my biggest song at the time
um and yeah people love it it's real
good I mean yeah if you're if you're in
New York I gotta give you a bottle I
need some mom's whiskey for sure yeah oh
yeah I just got into a uh not
necessarily an argument but I got into
it well I went viral because I went on a
podcast
and I said that I didn't think
that Drake nor J Cole had consensus
Classic Albums now oh I say that to say
I think they I think personally to me
Cole has two Classic Albums to me to me
and I think Drake's got well two
but I think like they don't have an
album that people look at in the same
way that they look at a doggy style or
get rich or die trying or a good kid Mad
City what are your thoughts which are
your your two for coal
I actually like Warren Center in Forest
Hills Drive okay I think Forest Hills
Drive is is that
um and then like and I really like I I
really do like the kod [__] is isn't
it's crazy it's crazy too I I and
obviously I mean I like off season off
season is like a year old so I can't
really say but off season was special to
me I think Friday Night Lights it's not
an album that well that's that's where
you get into the debate but to me that's
like I think that's probably my favorite
body of work from Cole me too Friday
Night Lights is crazy that [__] was
ridiculous yes so you so I think you got
that and I think his one is
um
uh Drakes is like take care and to me my
my favorite drink albums Is Nothing Was
the Same
Drake is hard because he he does the
thing you know where he tries to like
hit all the bases you know and it's so
it's like and it ends up resulting in
cool albums and cool songs but maybe not
the most yeah but I actually really like
nothing was the same to me as crazy
that's Tuscan Leather I mean Drake
straight yeah Drake's Drake you know but
I yeah that's a that's a tricky one I I
don't think it's like you know when you
look at Kendrick it's like
good kid Mad City to to pimp a butterfly
damn and now the new joint like that's
crazy certified it's crazy Classics it's
crazy it's it's insane I think we
actually don't give him enough credit
because
he's happening right now to pimp a
butterfly just on mediacritic.com or one
of those websites Anthony fantano always
be [__] talking about but on that
it's now the number one it just finally
surpassed
Okay computer by Radiohead as the number
one I saw that was critically acclaimed
album ever which is kind of crazy
shout out to pimpa Butterfly great album
it's my favorite album it's it's for me
it's either that or good command City
for sure but no it's just crazy because
like you said I just put up a post
yesterday
there's a picture that Jay and Kendrick
took at the Grammys and I was like
eventually we might look at this picture
and this is like 1a1b greatest rapper of
all time eventually I'm not saying now
but I'm like when the dust really starts
to settle on Kendrick's career
I I mean [__] man I don't know he's I
think he might
what's that oh the [__] Cable Guy
shout out to the cable guy that's the
new studio Jim Carrey no
um but no I think I think
I think Kendrick is on his way to being
the goat I think he's the goat right now
but but I I think it's like because to
me like not even on a big like so as a
rapper the older I get and the more I'm
get better at my craft the more I
realize like oh damn Jay-Z's the best
rapper why because the [__] he does and
the like the [__] dexterity and like
the
the versatility and the usage of less to
do more and [__] like that it's just
crazy yeah it's crazy but like with
Kendrick to me not even on no bigger
than rap shape not at all but Kendrick's
like to me he's like Michael Jackson
Prince like he he's in the capan of like
the best artists and performers ever and
when you look at like his live shows and
his performances and the musicality of
these albums and where they kind of sit
and then like I said the kind of
consistency I mean and he's being
consistent while taking pretty crazy
risks musically
and content-wise like if you really
think about like it's really hard for
people Kanye did a good job of that but
like to like take or think of do you
remember the common album uh Electric
Circus that everyone panned and hated
because they were like man what the [__]
is common doing like it's not easy to
like
take on a concept or take on like you
know like to pimp a butterfly sonically
was totally like way more funky and way
more complicated musically than good Mad
City and it was a little over a lot of
people's heads yeah still is people hate
on it people hate on that crazy people
are wild but that's what inspires me so
much yeah because the boldness of like
being the guy after good kid Mad City he
was the guy and it was like yo you're
the one like whatever and instead of
coming and trying to do some layup [__]
which is what people usually do they get
caught up in the apprais and the praise
that they get yeah like Drake
hey but um that motherfucker's a
thousand for a thousand on layups yeah
he's just laying it up just laying it up
yeah yeah that's why when Drake did the
EDM album or with this last [__] the uh
I was refreshed I was so happy yeah it's
not my [__] but I was like as an artist
yeah as an artist yeah the house album
there's some [__] on there and I was
like wow yeah great took a [__] risk
this is what I like to see yeah whether
I like it or not I respect the move bro
agree that's exactly what I said but
pimp to pimp a butterfly bro how do you
do that after after having the balls and
then for it to be that Sublime I mean
that dude is he's definitely he's my
he's my goat I always tell people
because I I have them in my like I got
them at about four or five but I always
say and I love Biggie but I'm like if if
because some people
especially old heads we'll be like nah
man you can't put Kendra listen if you
could put biggie in is your greatest of
all time
off two albums
you got to put Kendrick in that
conversation off of the four he's
dropped yeah I mean that's excluding uh
section 80. that's excluding the
Kendrick Lamar EP that's excluding
overly dedicated and Untitled and the
Black Panther soundtrack it's like what
are we talking about here the only one
who's done it is really Kanye with like
those first four or five albums being
Sublime like that like I mean who else
really cast yeah you know what's you
know what's true it's like I really
gotta dive in yeah I'm a New York kid
and it was one of those things where
like when I was going back I was going
back to let me check out tribe let me
check out Wu-Tang I gotta go at aliens
and Equipment yeah and I'm admittedly
like right there equipment on vinyl
right yeah I gotta I gotta go like all
my contacts with them was like I was a
kid when like speaker box love below
which is what won them to Grammy which
is was like you're like hey yeah this
[__] is cool but it's some pop [__]
that's the album right there hey we got
to stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our family at hardean that's
right Hardin Las Vegas the craziest
dispensary in the world the number one
dispensary in the United States let
alone in Las Vegas all right maybe
you're hitting Vegas with your friends
your girlfriends whatever maybe it's a
bachelor party whatever's going on
you're going to go watch the Raiders
suck [__] whatever it is make sure you
pull up to Hardy in Las Vegas tell them
I sent you they got the craziest
selection of Premium cannabis I've ever
seen in my [__] life the pre-rolls
the cartridges the Edibles the flower
all top notch all the best the bud
tenders are so friendly it smells great
it smells so good inside a Jardine that
they have their own Harding signature
scent candle
see I sniffed that and I just think of
Las Vegas and picking up some amazing
weed alright so go follow them right now
Jardine underscore Las Vegas shoot them
a follow get all the details you need
you can get you some of this fire ass
Jardine merch at hardinglasvegas.com
shout out to our family in Vegas I'm
excited too because coming up we're
going to be doing our very first podcast
from Jardin in Vegas with young gravy oh
yeah it's going down all right let's get
back to the interview hey we gotta stop
the interview to tell you about our
family at Odd Socks that's right the
most comfortable socks in the
[__] world go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsoxofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [__] else is going on with their
Black Friday so and let me tell you they
got some new licenses we got to talk
about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist and shout
out to all you rappers and people who be
pouring your lean into this [__]
some Mountain Dew Baja Blast socks
Casino great [__] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [__]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[__] [__] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [__] ethica or
some [__] ass [__] Nike socks
[__] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview yeah I gotta I've gone
a couple times but whenever I've gone
I've not been in the right my place to
receive this pair that's fair yeah no
that's fair yeah shout out to Kendrick
he's one of them ones man one he is the
one he's one of one man I mean whatever
I'm not trying to just like you know
kiss his ass but I feel you gotta give
people like that they're fine because
again I think there's certain times like
when we live with people
we have a lot of [__] in our time
but sometimes we have so much reverence
for old stuff that when something's
really Sublime and really special in our
era we feel weird about calling it that
Mike LeBron yeah
go ahead go ahead yeah yeah no I feel
like that's what happened that's what
happened that's what's happening with
LeBron yeah I think so I think so I mean
I'm a Jordan guy in terms of the goat
debate right but like but it's either
one he's two yeah my thing is if I ask
you who the goat is and you say anyone
but those two names then I really don't
know what the [__] we're talking like I
love Kobe he's right there him and
Jordan yeah but like living in La a lot
of people say Kobe's the goat
it's a Preposterous thing to say it is
and and I love Kobe but that is a
ridiculous basketball opinion to have
yeah no it's not I mean there was a lot
of years where he wasn't the best player
in the league at all like yeah I'm not
here you're trying to explain her when
Kobe was on the Lakers alone after Shaq
left they were in eight seed
two years in a row and they lost in the
first round well he was playing with
Kwame and smush
Kobe Bryant or Lebron James is playing
with [__] big Z Mo Williams Danielle
Marshall Off the Bench Larry Hughes
[__] losing player if I've ever seen
one like if Larry Hughes is your best
player on your team yeah he's like a
poor man's Monta Ellis who's a poor
man's Allen Iverson uh if these tanks
are getting better and better but not
the Monta Ellis man Monte Ellis was a
beast but like I just feel like LeBron
when he's when he I mean he's been on
super teams but I do feel like LeBron
when he's like when the cabinet's empty
he's still gonna I mean he got these
[__] to the Finals over the
Detroit Pistons yeah the year after they
won the finals yeah although I do feel
like there's too much made of the like
eight years in a row thing it's like
they they they were supposed to mop up
everybody in the East I'm not saying
that it's not a crazy accomplishment but
his black eye on his resume is that Mavs
lost with the heat 28 yeah yeah that's
the law that's the the finals loss where
it's like
should have had five yeah I can't even
fault him for the Spurs [__] because
that Spurs team was wildly talented yeah
but the the Mavs I mean it was Jason
Terry and [__] Jason kidding yeah bro
and the Warriors won like with that was
[__] I always felt like that [__] was
kind of [__] because I felt like he
threw his weight around to get that
Draymond suspension and it was like
they beat they beat but they won they
won the game seven with everybody
playing they beat the best regular
season team ever in the finals yeah they
did no they did 73 and 9 Warriors lost
to LeBron James they do yeah to me that
ring probably means more than any ring
ever
I don't know if I ever I'd have to I'd
have to give that I mean what's the
toughest what's the tougher ring to win
yeah yeah
I in theory I think though literally the
greatest regular season team ever
ever yeah they were down 3-1 I believe
they were but that but they came back
from 3-1 against the 73-9 Warriors but
they were gonna win and then he went in
the press conference with the Draymond
thing he was like the league won't
suspend him but they should you know he
threw his big weight around and then it
was like then they suspended him and
then it was like you know the rest is
and then they cheated and those guys
were exhausted and then they [__]
cheated and they got KD that [__]
shout out to Katie great guy good
hip-hop fan I met him I can't really say
anything bad about Katie because I've
been to his house and he was really nice
so he's really into hip-hop I saw him
and he's always running around with 38
Special now he's a super nice guy yeah
but he seems cool he definitely uh his
you know
some interesting decisions
it's a weird space now man I'm a very
old soul bro I'll be watching a lot I'm
stuck out with the Thunderman
but I but I feel like now in retrospect
we can kind of see why he left for us
yeah because Russ is a [__] can't
well
nice guy Russell Westbrook you know
we're gonna get you in trouble I
wouldn't want him on the [__] sons is
All I'm gonna say yeah it's tough like
the you know it reminds me of you know
to be honest with you for since you're
just being keeping it all the way funky
I feel like John Moran
will be Russ in three years if you don't
start to learn to play defense and get
some moves or he'll be in prison yeah I
heard about that [__] because he wants
to be king Von yeah
but I love John I love John's game but
the thing is it's like if you notice
they're almost as good without him as
with him because tyus Jones plays really
good defense they're very like his his I
think his style of play is
counterproductive to longevity in the
league that as well and like I think
yeah he he it very rust DeRose type of
guy so when you think of Russ like Russ
like electrifying like
I love like I used to love watching him
on the [__] Thunder just he was just
like a mo and Jaws the same way except
for dry I think is a little bit more fun
to watch than those those two guys but
like Derrick Rose was the same way it
was like
could you win a ring with those guys I
don't know man there and they'll turn on
you like the way they're all kissing
John's ass now everybody loves him but
and I love you too I love turn on it
like they turned on Russ that's what I'm
saying it's not like a hater comment
this is like I want to see him be
successful Jaron Jackson junior making
the All-Star game is [__] a travesty
by the way it's insane over who uh who
who was it that uh well first of all
Devin Booker should have made it even
though he's missed 21 games Jalen
Bronson should have been in there for
the east
over Halliburton
I mean I'll be all the way around with
you like over Julius if you watch the
games the numbers run denial so I
understand but if you really watch all
the games like in their totality like
and there was one All-Star from our team
to go and this come from the guy that
made the Julius Randle song like it was
Jalen has heard the song I don't know I
don't think so they played at the Garden
though yeah that was pretty dope he had
kind of a weird year last year he did
and that's why I said I'm not making no
more songs for people I like I think you
guys should fire tibeta get him out of
there man that old [__] bastard man
he literally doesn't coach offense bro
like he literally he just like yo figure
it out yeah literally like play whatever
you want yeah like 48 minutes a game but
he needs like uh the way Mike Brown was
coaching the defense like defensive
coordinator in yeah
offense yeah do it do that yeah not for
sure I like me shout out to the Knicks
man so you've got you got Jordan as your
goat Jordan's Margot Jordan despite
being a Knicks fan yeah yeah come on man
we you know I was 90s baby and we gotta
keep it real that's why the Knicks lost
because because of Jordan Jordan
[Music]
I'm not sure you guys were good enough
to get who whoever was in the west
during those years I'm not sure
I look back at some of those [__]
Knicks teams and like offensively just
not the greatest rosters they're just
Scrappers bro it was just like it was
like a bunch of Tony Allens and Patrick
Ewing yeah yeah yeah it was like John
Starks Anthony Mason yeah it's like
Mason and then there was like the funner
version of that team with Larry Johnson
you know Alan Houston there was but but
I'm talking about like the early 90s
Knicks teams it was just like Jesus it
was just Charles Oakley and elbows and
kneecaps and [__] Patrick Ewing
Alan Houston was a beast I mean listen
man them teams like I don't know those
those were battles with I was young I
mean I was like a little kid I remember
as a kid live on TV watching that
[__] Heat Knicks brawl oh no yo Jeff
Van Gundy is one of my top five favorite
humans he's great he does a great job at
being an announcer he's incredible like
when I listen to him on the broadcast
when he'll just go in on some [__] I
feel seen like as a curmudgeon that is
an old soul that just great [__] pisses
me off bro he'll just go off on some
[__] unapologetically and go off on the
league and go off on the state and like
it is like the greatest [__] I ever I
love that guy love love him uh okay so
if LeBron is two for you who's three
probably Kareem I think that's yeah and
you could make a case like like if
someone wants to come in and make a case
for Kareem at two like there's a case to
be made it gets weird error to error but
surprise about the past is [__] yeah
yeah it is but they changed rules for
that guy bro like in college I mean he I
mean and and the thing is like he you
kind of can't say like oh he wouldn't do
[__] today like he his man was mad big
he would just shoot that hook on anybody
like yeah you know yeah I don't know but
Kareem's probably three and then after
that you get into like
I got Duncan at five that's all I know
four four is probably Magic
what about Bill Russell see that's too
old it just starts to get weird that's
where the error [__] gets weird because
it was like he was never better than
will yeah but he got all the [__]
rings but he got all the Rings so and
then you got will as well because
everyone holds like every [__] record
damn near so you got to put him
somewhere in there I think of like who
would ball out no matter what era and I
don't know if Bill Russell could like
I don't know what he would do against
Dwight Howard in the paint yeah peaked
Dwight of course yeah
I'm trying to think when I think of like
a guy like Kareem like you said like I
could see Kareem thriving in today's
because he he could still cook yeah he
can still cook I think like
Larry Bird would be a [__] beast
Larry Bird is a beast bro and a Savage
when you hear like the trash talk
stories that's my favorite [__] but I'll
go on YouTube and just look up old like
trash talk stories that dude was a
monster would you say Nick's fans hate
Reggie Miller or Michael Jordan more
Reggie Miller oh that Reggie's serious
that was disrespectful that was old East
and those 90s East joints
yeah like [__] Reggie but also like it's
it doesn't feel like it feels very uh
separate basketball from the person like
on some [__] on some basketball [__] I'm
like yo [__] Reggie Miller but like when
I see him on TNT I don't get mad like
you know that's how I feel about Patrick
Beverly oh man that dude is that dude's
wild he's the dirtiest player ever that
dude's wild your man Chris Paul is kind
of dirty too though yeah he's not my man
he's not your man not no more a couple
years ago that I wasn't your man I got
all his jerseys
I got him we move off of him anyway
listen uh you got your new EP out yeah
but this comes out February 10th so by
that what's today by the time this is
out it'll be out yeah uh
new album soon album next year next year
and then I got a little something coming
for the summer too something for the
summer yeah what's coming for summer
it's gonna be it's gonna be mixtape time
again mixtape time yeah yeah are you
like uh I think do you feel like Who
besides yourself has the best basketball
references in hip-hop because you got
some pretty like
you got some like really random [__]
where like unless you're like a real
basketball nerd it's just flying over
your [__] I got it I did a good one
recently bro I had a keto turkaloo one
in there I love you I was so hyped when
I wrote that I was like he was on the
Suns for like one season he was good man
when he was on the magic think about
that they went to the finals and he was
their second best player [__] Jamir
Nelson Tito turquoise he was killing bro
I'll tell you the line when we're done
but it was like it was literally like uh
um Action Bronson got really good ones
he does and action bronzer he cuts super
random deep Cuts like super yeah deep
cuts and then uh
ah man who else is good I don't know who
else is there's a dude named Skillet
baby that's from Detroit young kid who's
got some pretty crazy basketball oh
baby Tron no he's on the freshman cover
it's [__] 18 19 year old kid and he
got he he's got the most random NBA
references for his age you'd be like bro
how old are you that's fine he's
shouting out bench players he's shouting
out the most random [__] and like he's a
kid bro like he's like a [__] child I
love that [__] yeah I'm like dog is that
Detroit yeah two guys from Detroit shout
out to them and a shout out to UMass a
new album next year new mixtape during
the summer yeah and then space two out
now out now go run it up and go watch
our freestyle it's about to happen oh
yeah boom